[Music]
nanami is the dad that itadori
never had i think out of all the complex
and tragic characters we've met in due
to kaizen so far
nanami kento is without any doubt the
most
complete character he just has stuff
figured out listening to nanome is like
listening to your parents or friends
when you
don't want to admit that they have a
point but they really do
and so interestingly enough in a world
full of eccentric
powerful and bad as characters it's the
ordinary
typical grown-up in the room that is so
relatable
and quite rightfully enjoys popularity
that rivals that of gojo
so
[Music]
still now right off the bat of course
despite his mannerism and appearance
there is
very little that's ordinary about nanami
in general
i mean the guy runs around with a blunt
blade covered in
anti-cursed charms basically butchering
his way through curses
but as you will see it's exactly this
contrast between the two worlds the
regular one and the jujitsu one that
makes him such a relatable and
intriguing person
this quote-unquote act he's putting on
of being just a regular tag-wearing
office guy in a slightly
unusual line of work is a central part
of his identity and moral perspective
so why did he run away from the jutsu
world what makes him so powerful
and what makes him one of the most
influential people for itadore
and the story overall this is the story
of nanami kenton
[Music]
okay first things first a quick trivia
regarding nanome's abilities as a
jujutsu
while nanami's name is written with the
kanji for 7 and
c his name can also be read as na na mi
as in
7 and 3. making it a bit of a pun with
his innate 7-3 ratio powers
that allow him to divide any target of
his choice with 10 lines
and then forcibly create weak spots at
the ratio point of 7-3
this ability is obviously extremely
powerful
but also requires excellent motor
coordination
that nanami demonstrates together with
fantastic athleticism
and strength and while not being able to
form his own domain
as a great one sorcerer he can use black
flash
a powerful application of concentrated
cursed energy
now probably the most interesting part
however is that nanami made a binding
vow with himself
called overtime limiting the amount of
cursed energy he can utilize when he's
officially on the clock working for
jujutsu high once he goes beyond his
shift and has to do overtime hours
however
nanami's cursed energy swells to an even
greater degree
granting him a significant boost in
fighting power
[Music]
while on the surface nanami might not
appear to be the most creative or even
complex character
you only need to go a little bit deeper
to find that in akutami's net of
carefully crafted characters
he is one of the most multi-layered and
well-thought-out personalities in the
story
this becomes very clear when looking at
his two main functions in the story
being a father figure to itadori and
drawing you
dear viewer deeper into the story itself
so
let's start with the latter to
understand what makes nanami so
important in terms of world building i
want to give you a quick overview of the
world in jude sukkaisen
more so than any other recent anime the
central principle in due to kaizen's
design is to integrate a supernatural
world of curses and sorcerers into a
real and timely depiction of
our normal worlds and as someone living
in tokyo right now myself i can
100 attest that akutami has taken the
japan of today and integrated his own
world as a hidden hub within it
now this concept in itself is nothing
new it's something we for example also
see in bleach
one of the major inspirations of the
story however while ichigo and ko
keep jumping from one world into the
next with rarely any references to the
real world
in due to kaisen both sorceress and
curses alike are part of modern
everyday life we see nobody shopping in
shibuya
tojo going to idol meetups gojo making
itadori watch
hours of famous hollywood movies
ghetto and the curses meeting up in a
family restaurant of all places and
even principal gakuganji first
introduced as the typical
old guy preserving traditions and
following the rules at any cost type of
character
turns out to use an electric guitar as
his weapon of choice
the most eye-catching thing however is
the use of smartphones in the story
as a nerdwriter one of my favorite
youtubers fantastically explains in one
of his videos
the reason we usually get so few
smartphones in movies and shows
is the addictive time-consuming and
never-stopping data mining we constantly
perform on our smartphones as a result
many of us have started to resent the
way that these devices control our lives
and
nourish our insecurities and fears but
our most popular movies
have never really been about confronting
our fears and resentments
hey man they're about escaping them for
a couple hours at the end
of a hard week jude so kaisen on the
other hand is
all about confronting fears and
insecurities and
figuring out what is worth giving our
time and
even our lives for and i think that no
other character represents this concept
better than
nanami he's depicted in a full suit and
tie
with neat haircuts nothing less than the
salaryman that gorju introduces him as
and without his unique sunglasses you
probably wouldn't even be able to
differentiate him from the common office
worker
he is the stiff serious formality in
contrast to gojo's easy
overly friendly and overly informal
attitude
during their very first meeting he
actually demands a formal introduction
from itadori
he's the type that likes to follow the
rules nanami's image as the ordinary
former salaryman
now back to being sorcerer helps us
connect to the world of jiu-jitsu kaisen
better than probably any other character
for him
office work is [ __ ]
but so is being a jew to sorcerer we all
can relate that working overtime in a
boring office job is not merely dull and
dissatisfying
it's draining anonymity putting office
work and jujutsu basically on the same
level
makes the actions of gojo itadori and ko
suddenly a lot more relatable
and real as well yes being able to do a
domain expansion might be
dope but in the end working yourself to
death as a jujutsu sorcerer
is just as [ __ ] a job as working
yourself to death as a salaryman
[Music]
and just like smartphones we usually
don't like seeing the unpleasantness of
a boring and draining job reflected back
at us
when we watch something and yet jude
skysen uses these elements consciously
to create a realistic
vibe while at the same time enforcing
the central moral question of the story
what does it mean to live a good life
worth living
nanami has a flat character arc in other
words
he knows the truth about the world that
most other characters still have to
figure out
nanami knows that in general the world
is mostly
[ __ ] jujutu sucks and doing a regular
job sucks life
doesn't present you with any deeper
purpose and happiness all by itself
nanami came to this realization after
initially running away from the terrors
associated of being a sorcerer
seeing his comrades die and suffer
around him had a deep
impact on him who as we will discuss in
a bit despite his hard shell has an
incredibly
soft core and so he decided to run away
work his ass off as a salaryman and then
earn enough so he could retire early
somewhere outside of japan way way away
from the juju world and all that
suffering
and yet in the end the office work
drained him just as much
and made him maybe even more unhappy
than his initial work
pointlessly thinking about money the
entire day and failing to live his life
in the moment right now and so initially
while it might seem like a minor part of
the story
the scenes of nanami visiting the bratz
store define his entire character the
most
as he ultimately decides to release the
girl from the burden of the curse on her
shoulder after all that neither she nor
any doctor could possibly see nanami
finally realizes that while life
is [ __ ] and offers no purpose in itself
he himself
is very much free to find his own
purpose and fulfillment in life
and so while he only inherited his wish
to help others from his grandpa and has
yet to figure out himself
why that actually matters nanami in this
moment understands that helping others
is what gives his life meaning and so
while being a jujutsu
might be just as bad or considering all
the violence and death
maybe even worse a job than working in
an office he has the rare ability to
help others who are suffering on the
terror of curses
and this conclusion is very important
because someone like mahito for example
also understands this truth about the
world however as a result
he decides to simply live out his every
desire to
fight and hurt humans
as always with flat characters in the
end the most important thing
is how they use their knowledge of the
truth to influence the world
either for the good or bad now the
second major role that nanami plays in
the story is that of the adult in the
room and
ultimately one of the most influential
people in itadore's development
this becomes especially clear when
looking at his relationships with yuji
gojo and even marito all three of them
are immature in very different ways
itadori of course is a literal kit who
grew up without his parents
and as with so many shonen heroes has
been thrown into a world of violence
mahito is a newly born curse that like a
child
plays around and tries things out such
as testing his own powers
or hanging out with a human to see what
they're actually like
finally gojo who is actually nanami
senior
can be quite serious and frightening at
times
but as i discuss in depth in his video
is nonetheless
emotionally immature
and while ironically all three of them
turn out to be strong at anonymi in the
end
when they interact with him their
immaturity becomes
more than clear
[Music]
nanami is in many ways an alternate
version of gojo
while gojo as the strongest sorcerer is
charismatic
eccentric and unconformist nanome is a
sorcerer who follows the rules
sees the work they do as a job and is
fairly reasonable and straight-laced in
his behavior
other than gojo he seems to believe in a
higher external set of laws that
everyone should conform to goodness and
righteousness in particular
are two ideals that define his life and
that end up shaping him
even if he himself tries to avoid them
he doesn't actually want to save
everyone or even the ones he holds dear
knowing fully well it's practically
impossible to do so
and yet whenever he's faced with the
option to help
he does while holding himself to his own
high standards all of this despite not
being a very self-righteous person
himself
gojo has a high opinion of himself but
low
social skills and low agreeability with
others
nanami as his inversion has a low
opinion of himself but is geared much
more to watching over and cooperating
with others
he does not let his personal opinions
interfere with his work
and so this results in nanami going out
of his way to cooperate with gojo
despite the disrespect he has for him
and his methods of handling things
[Music]
and this difference is reflected pretty
much perfectly in their approach to
teaching
while gojo is great at bringing yuji up
to speed in terms of power
basically crash coursing him into being
a first class sorcerer in mere
weeks due to his own character flaw he
can teach itadori on an emotional and
human level this is where nanami comes
in while he doesn't make yuji any
stronger in terms of power
he teaches him about morality duty and
in general what it means to be part of
the jutsu world
he also allows yuji who reminds him of
his own time as a student
to be a kid which even though it might
annoy him at first
is incredibly important for dealing with
the struggles that come with being a
teenager who suddenly has to make
complex moral decisions
like taking a human life and who's also
way too reckless with his
own life and so instead of throwing
itadori into the fire like gojo likes to
do
he gives itadore the option to say no
nanami is a sort of parental figure for
itadori that while strict
gives him a sense of security and
guidance
and most importantly he gives yuji a
feeling of achievement and attention
by believing in him and his abilities
in the world of jiu-jitsu it's the kids
that have to risk their lives while the
higher-ups pull their strings
safely behind the scenes away from the
action that's also anonymity keeps
saying things like
this
because he's trying to do what the
higher-ups should have been doing
all along keeping these kids safe and
allowing them to grow into responsible
adults
and actually this care for the students
and the dislike of the established
structures
is one of the few things that he
actually has in common with gojo
is an oddity among the sorcerer worlds
not for being eccentric
but for being too normal he's too much
of a functioning adult
he's not insane enough like most
sorcerers which is the case for a good
reason
and that's because nanami's number one
priority is not strength but rather
conformity in connecting and cooperating
with others
and so in the end nanami's
salaryman-like serious persona becomes
more and more of an act as you dwell on
his character
it's almost like he's putting on a show
that he's not as mad as everybody else
that he's still reasonable in this world
and i think it's done mostly for his own
sake because nanami is striving to
follow his own ideals of being good
in a world that he's well aware of is
not so good after all
and so while being an incredibly
sensitive and caring person at heart he
forces himself to be strict because he
believes that he has to
the moment that best chose this is
during his fight with mahito where he's
quite empathetic to the transfigured
humans mahito uses during their fight
despite claiming that he doesn't bring
his personal feelings to work
and it's exactly this fatherly nature of
his the feeling that there is an adult
in the room who knows what has to be
done
that make nanami such a well-respected
and dearly loved character
and even though despite his best efforts
nanami is simply not blessed with the
powers of a gojo or itadori
he's able to pass on his will and drive
to the next generation
and so while he might feel just like
another [ __ ] in the system
just like the accumulation of little
despairs made him grow
up it's the accumulation of these little
acts of kindness that are what create an
impact in the grand scale of things
making his life worth living which is
why in the face of death nanami is
actually able to smile
having lived his life in suffering but
without
now regrets in many ways is a more
mature version of itadori
having passed his philosophy onto him
the student that is actually most like
gojo
is not for shiguro but actually kugisaki
nobura
a refreshingly badass take on the female
support character in shonen
[Music]
make sure to watch her video by clicking
right here
thanks for watching peace